you've got the digital talk show
below-the-belt on showtime sports
correct okay you've got the fighter in
the kid podcast with Bryan Callen
Bryan's been on the show this is maybe
your fourth visit here this is how many
times have you had me on that podcast
big time this man this is my favorite
show you guys know this oh my gosh I'll
do I'll tell you number zero he's on the
you got the king in the state podcast
yeah what deal Vaughn it's going well
okay I know and the headline how about
this man I'm very excited for you an
upcoming Showtime comedy special that
premieres this Friday 10:00 Eastern on
Showtime you'd be surprised with Brendan
Schaub I know right Congrats bro thank
you sir
you've been working at this I've been
working you have literally been working
this I mean you've got a tour dates
starting in Cleveland Ohio at the very
end of this month and Burbank Vegas
Calgary Canada California Cincinnati
Indianapolis Nashville I mean you are
touring your own dog you are a murderer
join us I love it I absolutely love it I
love it I kid what I can't believe
though is that your your voters or your
fans voted the Blazers verse Milwaukee
yeah in the front come on that's not
real that's just the haters why they hey
what do you what do you mean I mean I
think Golden State Milwaukee's the
that's it yeah yeah there's not a lot of
Toronto clickers right now the Greek
freak risk Larry that's what we or a
healthy Durant I would want a healthy
Durant on the floor with the Greek freak
oh you don't know see now that that is a
narrative that I think a lot of people
are saying but I don't believe I think
they need them
I think they need him I think that they
did not need him to close out the
Rockets how about that I agree but I
think I think they're gonna win
regardless but instead of winning in six
games or five that's where I can take
seven well I mean not only all of that
is correct but to me it is let me get
the date right because again it's going
to be a great day
in New York Knicks history with the
ping-pong ball draft lottery tonight May
14th if this goes to a seventh game in
the NBA Finals June 14 June 14th they
got a full month to go here they need
bodies and if they don't get boogie
cousins back then they need Durant they
need Durant
that's what I'm saying you know that's
why I think game vert him on the floor
with Yanis but you're that's fun that
would be fun am I the only guy in here I
don't want I liked Zion Williams I don't
want to see him get drafted to the NIT
your fan why would you want him to go to
that it is so unorganized there you
don't want him to ruin his career by
going there and once I go it's a big
market everywhere it's a big market
still 19 he's fine so where would you
want him to go there's some there's
definitely better select hold on a
second I would leave one cleveland i
don't seem go to cleave careful look
under the LeBron shadow I don't want
that Brendan should I say cab rented
shop could be seen in Cleveland Ohio May
30th Lana be a good move for him I think
yes end up in the right spot man New
York's not it they're too dysfunctional
Phoenix Phoenix not mad at that Chicago
I'm frightened to that development by
the way that the Karma actually is this
is the second coming of Jordan and that
the Bulls are waiting for that I mean
he's the second come on Jordan you know
not know Airy Johnson is he not Shawn
Kemp Jordan that's a little aggressive
no it's aggressive but I'm saying I do
know what you're saying in terms of body
type and in terms of style I get it what
I'm saying is hope hope you sell the
home I'm selling a hope in the home of a
draft choice think about it think about
it last several number one overall picks
read him off Brockman or they say
they're not sad they're dynamite players
but I'm just talking about coming out of
college where the whole country was
watching and the whole country is seen
and the specimen the physical specimen
that that that that we have seen come
out a nanny draft first overall to have
that sort of hope he's all yeah we can
go back ten years we got John Dryden
last year mark L faults big bus Ben
Simmons karl-anthony towns could play
our Andrew Wiggins nothing blowing here
I'm talking about buzz and hope and the
whole fam basis gene play Anthony
Bennett one of the worst nuts ever
Anthony Davis High Roller Kyrie Irving
John Wall Blake Griffin Derrick Rose I
mean those last ones are monsters but
with with uh but coming out of college
though in turn they were monsters with
this much hype right but with Zion was
he six seven six seven six eight well I
guess the OB no no Perret perimeter game
so he's gonna have to go down low with
the big boys the the I guess comp at a
lot of people are mentioning is Berkeley
with him I know you had grandmama yes
III look more like I think more of a
Shawn Kemp a little more athletic maybe
what you're saying a lot right Brandi I
think Marie's the the guy who's gonna
fit in right away okay well I mean
you're talking about which which draft
I'm sorry I'm uh homeboy from drama ran
you talk yes he's gonna plug you I mean
I guess that by the way that is a hell
of a consolation prize is number two
overall that's probably not gonna be the
same hellacious equation I know but I
thought calamari certainly in the NFL as
a guy that has got that buzz to that
everybody's talking about right now yeah
and it one should be thanking their
lucky stars for Baker Mayfield or really
Russell Wilson that's true because
before the short quarterback no one
really kid and if you want to get could
even go back and say Brees you know drew
Brees but at all-time great you can even
go back and go Flutie on you can't
Charlie Ward sitting there like what the
hell what the hell bro what's play
basketball that's right we talk Kordell
Stewart the other day
Kordell coming out of college after what
he did to my alma mater throwing it to
Westbrook all the way into the end zone
you know that's my alma mater man
Colorado I'm a buff played played for
the Buffs did you really ask Stuart
what was your football playing career
Brennan I was uh oh three oh six Gary
Barnett years big twelve north chance
we got our tails kick though by Vince
Young for the Texas Longhorns and Jason
Williams and agent Peterson for Oklahoma
was joka teams was Joel clout your calls
my quarterback very good friend of mine
smart dude talk about small world I just
did the draft with him he's brilliant
he's dynamite he's great he's great now
he was when he was a quarterback in
college he was older because he played
baseball
yeah who's like the older kind of
right-hand man of the coach he'd kind of
boss us around but he's very smart
well you know III really enjoyed working
with him he was Elliot so I mentioned
Brandon shop here in the Rich Eisen show
all of your personal accomplishments
that you are killing it on right now
there's a big fight this weekend is
there not there's a big fight
Deontay Wilder Saturday night the
probably said the bomber here he comes
man the bomber dropping bombs against
Brazil it's a good fight Brazil's only
loss was against Anthony Joshua Lee lost
in the seventh round right it's a really
good fight too good it's a good I should
say test for Deontay Wilder because the
the real for the big three right you got
Tyson Fury
Deontay Wilder and anthe Joshua well
they're not fighting each other right
now so it's kind of you know the this is
what you're gonna get and and so it's a
good test and while there's definitely
fighting the the best match about a
definitely those three so it's gonna be
excited for it is it what I want no but
what's not the way boxing work so give
me I think I know what you want but tell
me what you want I'd love to see really
I'd love to see fury burst wild or two I
guess then there's a drawl but and then
you can throw in Anthony Joshua but the
three of them need to fight each other
they're ruining boxing by not fighting
each other it's heartbreaking now that I
work with Showtime you see the ins and
outs of boxing you to break your heart
right so what do you think needs to be
done if Brendon shop could wave along to
make this will work wave the wand the
promoters need to get out of the way
it's not about them it's about the
legacy of a box in the heavyweight
division so they need to not do what's
best for them but what's best for the
fighter because fury Joshua and Walter
they're not scared of anyone though they
would fight each other every Tuesday if
you give him the chance right
it's the promoters right it's always the
promote well I mean it's all about them
and trying to make sure that you get the
most out of it but these fighters I
guess they've left to their own devices
would just meet anywhere like right
right behind correct right behind our
said that that's the advantage if you're
a mixed martial arts failing with the
UFC right the best are fighting the best
they can't go anywhere there's a bit
basically one big promotion there's one
big promoter and Dana White so the
you're getting the best of the best all
the time well I
I shared a set with the bronze bomber
recently sir he shot an episode of
billions on the day that I did as well
they the dreadful math fee dollar bill
fight have you had him on Ian I have not
had him here yet he's great but I met
him and oh my god he is as big as you
would think he is but he's real real
skinny like his his ankles are like
judge him top to bottom bro I mean all I
was just like looking up he sits awesome
no big could have been nicer couldn't be
nicer took pictures of the everybody and
of course everybody wanted to take
pictures with him one of the best guys
in the sport and he was just awesome to
be around but I thought to myself man to
get in the ring with this guy you have
to have some yeah after some brass brass
to go against the bronze bomber here but
yeah he's amazing and I will tell you
this and this people I go you're Homer
first Showtime
the reason why you're not confer and
Joshua verse Walter it's not Wilder I've
seen the negotiations he want he'll do
anything make those fights happen right
it's all on the other side man it's so
heartbreaking I feel bad for Wilder I
feel bad for Wilder Brandon Shaw here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so what do you
like doing about what do you like about
comedy I mean what what what absolutely
lights your fire that makes you want to
just get on planes go to plays it's not
easy I know you're doing is serious
serious beating the bushes right here to
do this so I don't know absolutely I
just love it I love it absolutely love I
love be on stage it you know it started
here and in LA at the Comedy Store doing
my first set bombing and I don't know it
just it planted the seed inside me and I
start start going and start going and
then eventually probably a year and a
half after doing stem comedy Comedy
Central
they do this is not happening and had
this story that that's obviously a lot
better now because that was three years
ago at least I did this story of how I
went from fighting inside the Octagon to
finding comedy and that was kind of the
foundation of this special started there
and then I come up with an act adding
ten minutes here five minutes here next
you know you have an hour and then I
don't I don't know here we are I know
here you are and you got this special on
Showtime coming up you get so this is a
big weekend and Showtime for you right
now yeah it's a big weekend for me it's
the Brendon shop weekend I know man I
came here that's my first stop is that
really yes I appreciate any time that I
read that you're up for coming in we I
say yes every time yes my friends
specially in sports my favorite show i
watch all the draft stuff all combine
stuff love it man I appreciate that what
you should do you know I mean Irvin does
our red carpet stuff on the on the draft
you should bring your red carpet
abilities to the NFL Draft it could do
that I ditched E and now I go to freakin
than a film that well I mean yeah I'll
do that
you and Irv would be a great amazing
Ervin's the best people I've ever met
yeah when did you meet him oh he lost
full-time I know he loves a fight yeah
during my fights during he loves the
fight game about like as a party with
Tim T well we went to this Superbowl
party by the way they get this story not
started a party and there's this is
years ago and Irvin knows me from the
UFC cuz at one of my fights he saw me
and we had this long conversation you
know passion he he drips passion of my
gosh one of the most amazing people I
look at my daughter's baby naming my
wife nice my wife I'm judge he's done
he's amazing he's the world he dropped
the mic at my heels oh good he's so
passionate so I'm at this party he knows
me from my fighting days and at the time
I still fighting I walked in this party
and there's like you know the who's who
that Deion Sanders you know Charles the
who's who
like in front everyone he goes be
shocked I'm like I don't want attention
like oh no and there on my kid what's up
instead of going for a high-five he
grabs my head pushes me down and it was
awkward cuz I kind of resist like no I
don't know what set of damn straight you
to okay so we got a big fight on
Showtime coming up this weekend on
Saturday and then on Friday you be
surprised at 10 p.m. Eastern time with
you on Showtime I am available to come
on your podcast really I don't
understand well in loves you two minutes
I know and I love when he's on the show
it's a triangle of love I know you know
and by the way and you're right from
your than both of us you know all I'm
saying is this I can only offer I'm not
one of those types in this town oh yeah
I'll look to your podcast and the door
and I'm like I'm never doing this
podcast buffers I'd love to show up on
places that people don't expect me to
show I would love that
let's do a bank on it bank on it no
don't say that I'm telling you man I've
been waiting on for a while okay how
it's gonna go - usually I just whenever
there's a big combine a draft coming up
yeah I just spit facts at Callen he
doesn't know you so excited the guys
goes oooh he looks strong man yeah
they're all like that's not that's not
the way you he blew his mind we saw that
DK Metcalfe the Daniel Jeremiah's
nickname for him was a human bat suit
that's a great name but he said a human
bat suit is what he is DK met kafirs and
now he's gonna be on Seattle and he's
gonna be running routes and Russell
Wilson's gonna try and rainbow it into
him one of the many exciting aspects
coming out of draft for this fall also
the Arizona receiver that went to new
ink
I think that flew under the radar yeah
kids Nikhil Nikhil Haris have you
watched the pac-12 he was a stud Hey
look the Patriots had a choice of
every-every wide receiver I think not
named Hollywood Brown at that point in
time right backed and they chose him a
little toy for Brady you're fired up
over there are like 10 more years he's
gonna keep playing thank you for coming
on yes thank you that good luck with
absolutely everything you're doing I'm
sorry I don't know if there's enough
time in the 40 summer minutes of the
show for me to run through everything
again but so where's a website that
everybody could catch up on everything I
know you got almost a million followers
on Instagram at Brendan Schaub and
that's your Twitter account is what's
your take it's a my stamp TFK calm and
then we did all access behind the my
clean up to my special that's on
below-the-belt youtube page you can see
it there fantastic Brendan Schaub here
on the Rich Eisen show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app